on va continuer à vous parler des
produits de la mer cette fois du nouveau
brunswick de la baie de fundy plus
précisément c'est que cette semaine
encore enfouies dans nos archives pour
souligner le 20e anniversaire de
l'épicerie et là on va remonter quinze
ans en arrière c'est qu'en 2007 notre
collègue barbara gauthier était allé à
la pêche aux petits gourmands
c'est savent se produite et biologiques
bienne avant que le biologique
deviennent populaires il n'y a aucune
transformation
ici j'ai dû petit gourmand qu'un algues
locale que les gens mangent les gens de
la région des glucides surtout la baie
de fundy il va manger sort avec des fois
avec une bière genre au lieu de manger
des cacahuètes au bar il va manger de sa
taxe est une spécialité locale
[Musique]
le petit gourmand et une halle qu'on
retrouve dans la baie de fundy laisser
celui de l'île de grand manan au nouveau
brunswick qui est le plus réputé
donc les trois grands types d'algues
c'est les algues vertes les algues
brunes et puis les algues rouges et sa
ces deux types d'algues rouges le petit
goémon et puis le nord les gens font
juste de manger accrue comme ça moi par
contre je m'en sers un petit peu dans ma
cuisine parce que c'était juste les
produits de la région je vais m'en
servir dans une recette avec avec le
nourrit l armée norris est quoi le
norris un sénateur japonaise
sanad qui est mis en file pour faire les
sushis tout ça mais cette agglo n'a pas
de comptes nantes celle du tout avec vue
que le
le petit gourmand un petit peu salée
j'ai mélangé les deux ensembles
moitié-moitié qui fait comme un mariage
j'ai fait que le plan soit pas trop
salée c'est une halle donc les gens
aussi bien dans les maritimes que aussi
dans les états de la nouvelle angleterre
les gens mangent ça depuis très
longtemps bon c'est aussi une tradition
qu'on retrouve par exemple en europe
dans tous les pays je dirais d'origine
celtique la bretagne en france l'irlande
le pays de galles les gens mangent mange
ça depuis des siècles et donc les gens
vont ramasser ça à la main et puis
mettre dans l'est dans l'es5 mais ici on
est juste au début de la zone de petits
gourmands et donc ils vont partir avec
leur bateau ramasser un petit peu plus
loin et là des rochers vont être encore
beaucoup mieux couverts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'industrie du petit goût et meaux a
conservé son caractère artisanal les
façons de faire ne pas changé depuis des
siècles cela joue la couche de téflon
sous l'embarcation qui permet de
franchir en dix ans la digue de cailloux
[Musique]
une fois cueillies les petits gourmands
seront nettoyés avant d'être séché par
la suite ils seront acheminés jusqu'à l'
usine
ces petits goémon proviennent de dons
voilà à quoi ça ressemble quand on les
reçoit oui
si les algues ne sont pas complètement
sèche le sel va s'accumuler comme ça on
n'aura pas un produit de première
qualité et bien deuxième qualité
en usine les petits gourmands peuvent
être réduits en flocons ou tout
simplement emballé et distribués dans
les commerces
il y a plusieurs façon de déguster le
petit goémon on peut le manger comme des
croustilles utilisée comme condiment
pour assaisonner souper chez les
poissons ou tout simplement l'ajouter à
une salade comme tout les ags le petit
goémon est une source de protéines
complètes et contient aussi des oligo
éléments et des sels minéraux comme
lionne et le potassium
[Musique]
et
à
fait que je vais les angles filière en
brochettes donc là je vais rajouter un
tout petit peu de poids
moi je dirais que le petit gourmand bout
la mer
avec la mesure que ça cuit je vais juste
faire de tournée
nous avons à la couleur qui change aussi
on y passe du mungo verdâtre et ont fait
qu est-ce qui va apporter à la soupe de
poisson
ben il va apporter un petit goût plus
marraine c'est à dire que le le petit
gourmand un petit peu un goût de
un goût de la mer ça fait que ça va
rapporter soit ma soupe de poisson qui
va faire ça va donner une saveur plus au
temps t convenir aux à la mer
[Musique]